but over time she'll know which which
battles - you know you got to pick and
choose your battles
[ __ ] battles she could pick with me
the video game thing you don't how long
has it been since you've heard anything
about the video game cuz he doesn't play
them anyway yes he does all day or you
got a plan Donkey Kong and stay here
okay do you scream like him when he
plays yes no you don't know cuz I hear
you oh my god the baby he screams louder
than me
yes I'm yelling we having a great time I
know how much we missed Bobby but you
know what - your greatest man he is a
better human being he's like morph I
can't play with you because I'll tell
you why okay I I gained resentment deep
resentment I gained um I start like kids
all you know what because there's kids I
play with your own destiny them yelling
at me and tell me what to do oh yeah I
know it was literally kind of going what
the [ __ ] am i doing
remember when we started playing it was
just you and I and we were like oh we
gotta get somebody else so we got Steve
in yeah and then we got like oh that's
what Craig came in we started to get all
these people but once we started
expanding into like people we don't know
I'm right there with you we were like
here's the thing you guys suck when did
you ever win anything but the fun of it
it was the camaraderie of it but here's
the thing so yeah I mean the more we
played for Stephanie how have I never
been to the lighthouse no I'm never
going to write why what do you want to
live like that
I hate listen I totally understand what
you're saying I know I get as equally as
frustrated with this [ __ ] game I'm
playing and I might they're doing like
trials or some [ __ ] yeah you know like
and I'm like I hate this I'm not having
fun like I'm literally not having fun
because there's no way to get better at
it like I don't care like I change
controllers get the different gun
because I like playing with you guys
that's what it's all about
yes Bobby don't you remember we became
friends because we were in the Middle
East playing xbox on the road that is
true can you guys find a different
interactive game other than definitely
was screaming and we're gonna do a
podcast together I see that all things
comedy together yeah
I was in the car when you made the phone
call and I told you to go to that
meeting and you didn't the second time
around anyway what the mics did you buy
a mic Oh see this is okay you got
recognized that him and I this room you
think this room would look like this it
would be crazy in here you wouldn't be
doing a park and he's playing Destin I
still think that you guys should do a
podcast together and I've always said
what's your [ __ ] pity podcast
although you me and Steve could do on
short good I think you should like once
a month they do a special one yes you
guys should do Eric jeans induced Lee
yeah yeah the twitch thing going on
anymore established do you hear the tone
I know